folks joe derosa here guess who's back
on the road officially the run
has almost
begun
i don't have a name for this run yet of
shows quite frankly i don't like what
people name their that doesn't matter
listen here's where i'm headed july 9th
fairfield connecticut july 14th through
16th san francisco california july or
sorry august 12th through 13th atlantic
city new jersey september 1st through
3rd san diego california september 12th
somerville massachusetts and then dates
to follow in wilmington holland michigan
grand rapids michigan man i'm back out
there
go to joey
go to jotaro
fudge
go to rosa info.com go to
joederosainfo.com
and you can get your tickets there for
most of the gigs and the ones that
aren't there yet will be there very soon
that's
joederosainfo.com for tickets also while
you are in new york city
you see it here we're in the rv at joey
roses come to joey rose's
in nyc the sandwich shop and bar for all
your sandwich and alcohol needs 174
rivington street we're open tuesday
through sunday
joeyrosesnyc.com for details thank you
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the
so we're going to do this as a three-way
battle each person has their is their
own man
uh we have three islands battling today
nate ice cream
versus sal cookies versus me cake
three-way battle of three amazing
versatile dessert foods here
uh i mean these are these are three
titans so this is a big one this is it i
mean if we had a fourth guy on pie this
would be game over question this was
cookies versus is it was it cake or
cookies versus ice cream cookies ice
cream was the original battle and i did
ice did i scream one and you took
cookies
which is why you got cookies again today
i took ice cream in that battle and did
win was it close
i don't think so oh well then what am i
doing here today no no i don't think it
was a slaughter but i don't but it
wasn't like neck it wasn't like oh my
god this is unfair look how close it is
now we also i believe at one point did
cake versus pie did we not i could i
could pull up the i could pull it up um
i think pie is
not even in the ballpark i mean i
wouldn't
i would agree
but you know i don't even i like pecan
pie we did apple versus that was my big
i did a terrible oh that's right we did
apple pie versus peach pie people like
what's a peach pie i meant peach cobbler
i really should have done blueberry or
cherry pie is what i really should i
don't even nate as the guest of honor
today
why don't you kick us off with your
opening defense argument of why ice
cream is so important to you why you
think it's the king of these
three foods
it's beating these out in the desert
department
it's
i think it there's everybody loves it
and like even the like i'm i'm kind of a
normal person with ice cream i don't go
too crazy uh i think ben and cherry ben
and jerry's is kind of out of their mind
right now and like if they're getting
it's getting too wild and you look at
like just a chocolate of vanilla and
like they're it's you know they got them
together chocolate is such a giant fan
of chocolate
ice cream chocolate ice cream is is my
go straight up i'll do it straight up i
also put it in a cup and i'll pour milk
in it and eat it with a spoon is that
some southern thing i think it might be
a southern thing but i don't know but i
like my i'll let it melt but you add
milk i'll add milk and then i eat it
whole milk yeah
yeah so it makes it like a milkshake it
makes like a milkshake but not like a
chunky milk like it's you know
and you drink it liquidy or you no no i
eat it with a spoon but but what's the
container and you got a little drink at
the bottom so so it's you mix the ice
cream into the milk or the milk just
sits there right and you're eating the
ice cream as you normally would yeah
just kind of dipping in the milk a
little bit and then the milk eventually
becomes the surprise that these are good
enough
once you say once you say that it's like
a milkshake then sure i get it but uh i
do think it's a little odd to pour milk
on top of ice cream i think they go
together very well i respect it but uh
i think uh
here's i i got news for you this is
going to blow your socks off a little
bit we argued chocolate versus vanilla
ice cream vanilla one considerably
is it count putting stuff on it or it's
like straight up no we were saying just
the best base flavor then the other you
shouldn't even be allowed to do this
podcast no i was team chocolate i know
you should be like it should be just you
joe
and this is maybe this is why john's
such a big fan of you is because this is
insane chocolate excels in chocolate bar
form chocolate people love when people
say i'm addicted to chocolate a lot of i
think first and foremost they mean
actual chocolate you you get you start
dabbling in ice cream the van the
madagascar vanilla bean the the purest
vanilla
there's nobody homemade vanilla
i could see it coming out of uh like the
that's my favorite ice cream what's the
soft serve yeah soft serve is like
favorite ice cream is uh i mean if you
if you if you're lucky to stumble upon
that it's an honor and like you go and
and you just have to go do it the truck
might pass today the weather's here do
they do the soft surface oh they don't
do it at the bar it depends right now
i'll say this softie's coming through
all three of these foods chocolate rains
chocolate cake is the best cake
chocolate ice cream is we both degrees
the best ice cream and a cookie ain't
[ __ ] without a chocolate chip vanilla
doesn't really go with cookie but uh
vanilla cake sounds odd but i love when
you're doing a bacon like a betty
crocker or duncan hines i like vanilla
on vanilla is my favorite you're talking
about a yellow cake i think a yellow
cake but the yellow is
or a butter yeah
so your vanilla can't even stand on its
own name that they have to go well it's
yellow cake and you're like i guess i'll
get it if they said vanilla cake you'd
walk out of the place they go why would
you even do something like this they
can't dye it white
even vanilla like true vanilla cake
flavor
they gotta call it birthday cake yellow
is vanilla let's be honest no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
a vanilla cake with vanilla you're going
to get a vanilla flavored cake
you're getting butter flavor babe that's
why it's yellow that thing is riding on
butter all right this is here no there
okay okay because you're wrong ice cream
okay he's taking ice cream for me ice
cream i got to be in the mood for it uh
it's cold all the time right
for me i like a treat that's either room
i like a treat that could be cold hot or
room temperature cookie could do all
those things i put cookies in the
freezer i have cookies out on a plate
and and a fresh baked warm cookie is the
best you've ever the only food you're
getting ice cream you got about eight
minutes with a cookie and then it just
becomes like might as well pick it up
off the street
that's what that's what cookies hook up
you got what's there unless you walk in
and it's you have to put a clock on a
cookie for it to be unbelievable you're
not gonna look at yourself as a man in
the mirror michael jackson whatever you
put a clock on ice no one's leaving ice
cream out for all day like you don't
just leave it out three minutes or
that's it dude i know but it's in the
freezer you go to the freezer and grab
ice cream it's supposed to that's where
it lives it lives in an igloo
you're cooking you tell me your cookies
carry it around everywhere i got a
cookie oh boys we got a hot one today i
put a cookie in front of me and i said
an eight minute alarm in eight minutes
it beeps my cookies no good you might as
well throw it and it's gonna break a
window it's it's your you bring cookies
you make them at home and you take them
to a party well the journey they have to
go on is a nightmare and so when it gets
there your bait's like oh these cookies
are good and then your teeth are burnt
it's breaking into [ __ ] crumbling it's
crumbling everywhere it's a mess you
mean you mean a crunchy cookie and then
you got your shag carpet and everybody's
like are you kidding me dude i just
bought this and you got a microwave by
the way i want to point out too nate i
want to point out to you something that
sal loves doing this podcast he loves to
do this he loves to exp to say that he
likes to eat a food in a way that nobody
eats the food where he goes i'll put a
cookie in the freezer no you won't no
one does that why would you do that you
could eat a freezer
i made homemade chip witches ice cream
involved but i put the cookies and i
wrapped them and i put them in the
freezer i do because ice cream is on the
cookie
what yes i made a chip which but if you
listen to me here's something that
cookie has that neither of you have i'll
put thin mints in a in a uh
free refrigerator that's like that's a
that's a girl scout sure nothing meant
there's a cookie buddy i know that's not
a cookie a thin mint i think it's a good
man
it literally is a girl scout cookie a
thin mint i think the girl scouts go
faster
i think how about that i think the girl
scouts run fast and loose with that term
cookie quite frankly girl scouts are
doing things for this world that you
will never achieve and do not talk down
about those things and you don't have
girl scout ice creams and you don't have
the girl scout cakes it stood the test
of time they are an amazing institution
in our future and they chose cookies
they're fun because they can't push a
ice cream cart you mention what they
want to move some stuff push a dippin
dots cart girl scouts
how about you do that unreasonable
that's well that's the best dippin dots
is the greatest thing he's ever had in
my life
they deliver the cookies get delivered
you can't deliver a dippin dot you push
it hold on a second
in a second hold on a second let's stop
acting like the girl scouts are heroes
what else are a bunch of eight-year-olds
gonna do with their time they've got the
time to deliver cookies
they could be up watching dvds getting
out of here doing anything but they're
they're doing charitable work
what are you talking about what i'll
take you now to they're keeping america
fat
is that what you want let me take you
now it's all awesome let me take you now
to the glory of cake
he's about to say something that cookies
have that you guys don't have what good
you could eat a cookie fully soft baked
i mean hot piping hot soft as hell you
could eat a cookie like a tate's that is
about crisp through and through you can
eat a cookie that has a crisp on the
outside with a goo on the inside the
cookie is the most versatile you can
have it hot cold or room temperature all
these variations all these different
textures it's something nobody wants a
cold cookie something cake can't do it
nobody wants your salted mushy ice cream
is freezing cold whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
hold on a second you can absolutely have
cake warm you can have cake hot you can
have at room temperature and you can
have it cold i've taken cake straight
out of the fridge and sliced it i've
taken keg out of one of those
glass domes uh at room temperature and
eaten it i've had a piece of cake
straight out of the oven and eaten it
you can have textures though your cake
is just it's a saucepan
i had ice cream cake the other day
ice cream cake is my most hated thing
well that's crazy that's crazy scam
that's nice
that's crazy how is it that's crazy you
shape ice cream into the form of a cake
and then tell the kids because it's
versatile ice cream is versatile ice
cream could be uh cook they put cookies
with ice cream in the middle because
that's how much cookies need help they
need help cake they can't stain on their
own it's ice cream in the form of a
chocolate chip cookies the only thing
they came up with ice cream into a form
of a dinosaur i mean it's a dinosaur let
me take you to why let me take you to
why the cake is superior to the cookie
first of all let me just start there
okay when you go to the bakery aisle in
a supermarket you see everything that
that supermarket makes it is cake city
in that aisle okay there's a few cookies
there's an answer oh there's a few
cookies there's an afterthought eagle
shelf space when you go to the dessert
a bakery a bakery has equal parts cookie
and cake you're not even in it you're
but it's cool you're you're bat you're
wrong you're you're you're not because i
got my own shop because we don't even
have other stuff ice cream shops are
just this is what we do dude because we
are this is our thing and we don't need
help i don't need to need a cake to be
like come on i need you to move some
tickets and i need a cookie over here to
help out we're just ice cream this is
what we do and maybe you walk by a
bakery and you go hey guess what i'll
throw a cookie in my ice cream so i can
eat it but i will say this about the ice
cream shop there's a reason the ice
cream shop is like that it's because
they can't fathom that the pig trash
walking into that place
would ever be sophisticated enough to
buy something like a cake they said they
pee these people can't wrap their heads
around anything they can't immediately
ingest with a spoon as they walk all
right i mean your your your pick for
today is is leading to the deaths of
people in this country you got people
walking through the streets down in 1500
calories each and when you normally do
this when you normally eat ice cream on
a hot day and as soon as you have ice
cream from the from the goddamn truck of
the store on a hot day you are on the
clock you have the balls to talk about
eight minutes for a cookie oh he did in
the wintertime they had a winner i'll
eat ice cream
in the street with a cone and you're
literally gonna drip all over you that's
the worst part that's you're barely in
those situations you're barely in them
barely prime ice cream time that's the
situation all the time well when they
invented the freezer it helped out to
eat it home a lot so no one this is in
1924 where you can only eat ice cream
out on the street but you want an ice
cream this is what they're doing
you buy a cone the the truck passes by
you get a cone i'll give you another one
nate better be good i'll give you
another one now now you get to it quick
you can read it it's good for those of
us
catches the ice cream melting because
it's been such a problem you can eat
that too i'll give you another one for
those of us that live in society
sal and me new york this isn't an issue
but for guys like you that live i don't
even know where you live nate what is it
tallahassee
yeah
you're you live near some swamp yeah
it's a good 90 minutes to that grocery
store you're not getting that ice cream
home cleaning and you know you're not
i'm going through a refreezing process
which is bad bacterially yeah no you're
not you get the ice cream real quick we
everywhere outside here is a normal
place that has grocery stores and you so
you can like go you guys have to walk
and take a subway so you got eight
blocks it's gonna take you 40 hours to
get there i gotta go everything's gone i
bring a cart up two blocks
and you get an ice cream in under 10
seconds i i get that but i'm saying if
you want to take it home if you want to
take it home and you want to do it it's
going to melt at home last year on the
news it was huge all over people were
opening ice creams and licking them
during cover and putting them back in
you remember that what they had to they
had to put like i think people got jail
time a felony it became a felony because
they caught people on camera opening
like the briars or whatever it was the
turkey hill licking it and closing it
back up so who are you blaming ice cream
for that that's not ice cream ice cream
is just sydney cookies that's another
problem i have that's not a problem i
have with ice cream a lot of the brands
you go into the freezer at the
supermarket you get your pine ice cream
half of these brands you peel that top
off no plastic yeah nothing that's wild
you can get right into that ice cream
it's crazy you can see you can see it
you can see it you open it up you know
if it's been tampered with you know if
it's been tampered with you're really
gonna i feel i feel great about it it's
in the cold cover can't live on it
that's a sign that's i read that in a
magazine on the way here and that's
it's you know your cookie i mean my god
it started in cook
thrives in the cold it's the heat it
can't live it correct no that's true
yeah well that's i don't think what i
don't believe in covet so whatever
[Laughter]
that's it we're like the comedy cell
table on vaccines what you got the
vaccine
are you kidding me you got covered
flavored yes you got ben and jerry's
though listen to me another thing i
don't like about actually speaking of
getting it at home and buying it in that
jug
you ever go and you're like you know
what i want some ice cream you have it
in the fridge you take out the half
gallon pint thing that and you to open
the briers and then all of a sudden you
can't get a jackhammer into that ice
cream forget about taking like a
tablespoon and trying to dig in you hurt
your palm you have to wait 15 a
tablespoon eat your ice cream but who's
even there's ice cream scoopers that
this is what they do
you go go to baskin robbins they're
doing it all day these kids have
forearms that are i mean they look like
uh
train workers they're like getting
injured like the guy playing tracks i
don't like that you ever see that and
it's right you ever have company you
know anybody want ice cream and they
take it out and you go to the like [ __ ]
i will say yeah i will say so
as we wait to make cookies what do you
do you pick your chips ahoy out you're
gonna bring a bag out you know how
embarrassing that is you got a party
over you're like i made some cookies
they're in this bag of chips they've
been selling grocery store for 40 years
well who's gonna who's gonna say that
cookie's gonna take out chips the people
the cookie people because the cookie
people are you know they just act like
they all people want homemade cookies or
they don't want cookies
that's that's that's that statement you
sound like someone oreos i would give
you maybe oreos are the only ones and
that's inappropriate at a party he's
inappropriate at a party i'll say this
right now [ __ ] oreos and [ __ ] you
no you're crazy that's crazy oreos
you're still salty from the
match one oreos
dominated chips ahoy yeah well yeah they
it's much better if you dip on milk it's
a it's a whole it's a really good
experience you dare bring that argument
in here right now here you go if you got
it in milk it means the food's not good
enough on its own no no it makes it nice
and soft i could eat it on its own i'm
family you don't know you give me a box
of oreos i'll eat them on their own i
don't mind they're better chips away
yeah dude i don't think everybody yeah
i'm not it's not
wouldn't even that's not good we're
together on the chocolate well how can
we differ on this
uh that is not famous i look a bit like
cake i will say this i want to start
cheating on cookies again okay
uh
when when your food predominantly comes
in a bag it's trash food your food
predominantly is served in a bag
and that is so fun that is so stupid
you can't serve cake in a bag and now
all of a sudden cake is distinguished
and cooked it comes in a wonderful did
you have you've seen the presentation on
a cake a wonderful car you know it's
been you know it's been
people took care of it
it's got the cellophane you can see
inside
cookies come in a bag happy birthday
janet it's nice
can i say something can i say something
here's something i'll say about cakes
and it's going to be a truth bomb
i like a homemade cake like you mix it
and you put on your own icing and you
make it at home outside of that
cakes are a scam you ever go to a bakery
they look amazing they look oh my god
look at those the glaze on that thing
the strawberries look how cool it looks
look at the decorations look at the
cream you cut those bakery cakes up when
you get home they're okay yeah if you
buy the one there but they they make it
so it's like it's like showing you
here's what we can do but it's loaded
with sugar it's usually bland and i'm
talking about what a cookie is healthy
i'm gonna get it i'm saying i'm gonna
cake outside of a homemade cake at home
for me they are underwhelming i'm gonna
hit you with a string
of banger cakes right now string ready
yeah chocolate cake with chocolate and
chocolate yellow cake with buttercream
ice cream icing or chocolate icing hold
on red velvet cake with cream cheese ice
cream icing carrot cake with cream
cheese icing
lemon cake
traditional
grocery store sheet cake with the sheet
cake icing
traditional birthday cake with the
rainbow speckled icing dude it goes on
and on cookies what do you have i think
that's you got a chocolate cookie you
got an oatmeal cookie yeah you got a
chocolate chip cookie macadamia nut
squash you think you're you're getting a
listener by saying that what do you mean
like you think that people will believe
there's three cookies because you only
named three folks magic spoon baby it's
been a minute where you been magic spoon
we're back baby who loves cereal i love
cereal who loves eating kid cereal none
of this grown-up crap geez god this
grown-up crap cereal is the worst
i like eating fun cereal i like fruity
cereals and chocolate type cereals
cinnamon flavored cereals all stuff like
that and that's where magic spoon comes
in because they're letting me eat the
cereals
that remind me of the cereals that i
that i had as a kid but i could eat them
now as an adult and they don't have any
of the bad stuff in them isn't that
great you know when you're a kid you can
eat a box of cow chocula and burn it off
in an hour running around through
sprinklers you can't do that as an adult
trust me if you run through sprinklers
as an adult looks weird
so magic spoon bring it into your life
bring it into your diet i love what
these guys are doing uh here's the thing
uh i if you're trying to cut down on
carbs and sugar and unhealthy food it's
look you sometimes you feel like you
can't eat anything fun anymore but nope
magic spoon you can have magic spoons
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four net grams of carbs
in every serving that's amazing only 140
calories per serving keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
and gmo free and you can build your own
box available flavors uh you know you
can they've got a ton of available
flavors you select the ones you like and
you build your own custom bundle i mean
you know you put a you get a cocoa box
and a fruity box and a peanut butter box
or a blueberry box whatever it is magic
spoon is here to do the thing you want
them to do go to magicspoon.com taste
buds and grab a custom bundle of cereal
try it today try it what are you waiting
for get off your ass try it and be sure
to use promo code tastebuds to check out
and save five dollars off your order
that's magicspoon.com taste buds and use
promo code tastebuds to get five bucks
off your first order folks i want to
talk to you about nicotine
more specifically the product named lucy
lucy in the sky
giving you a ray of hope why you got a
nicotine a dix
why not take that nicotine into your
body in a much better healthier way okay
uh sucking smoke down for your nicotine
fix is not the best way to do it folks
it's 20 22. there's a better way all
right now i got to read this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
that's why i'm talking about nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical but
here's the thing if you enjoy using it
you should definitely check out lucy's
products at
lucy.co that's lucy.co and when you go
to lucy.co i want you to use promo code
taste buds at checkout okay
this is again a way to get you to get
your nicotine fix in a better way maybe
that leads you in the right direction
with your
other nicotine products and the amount
that you're using them
i believe that this is a good thing to
implement and if you're a nicotine user
so again i want you to go and by the way
i've used lucy this is
hand to god sorry the wrong hand up hand
to god i've used lucy i think it's a
great product and i think it does
exactly what i'm saying it will do so
again go to lucy.co
that's lucy.co and use promo code
tastebuds at checkout
uh hey everybody thanks for watching
taste buds uh do us a favor and
subscribe on uh the no press channel
follow us on spotify leave a comment on
itunes that's a huge way that you could
help us that cost you no money if you
want to help the podcast and you love it
merch is available for taste buds on our
website you go to salvocanocomedy.com
for mine
joedorosainfo.com uh tour dates this
weekend i'll be in rochester and
syracuse june 10th and june 11th come on
down that's coming up right now uh the
following weekend south bend indiana
june 16th milwaukee june 17th
minneapolis june 18th weekend after that
you got hampton beach casino ballroom
june 24th and foxwoods in connecticut
june 25th that's two shows that night
and just looking ahead we got vegas on
july 15th first time headlining vegas at
the virgin hotel theater and then we got
phoenix boulder portland seattle and
vancouver rounding out july salvolcano
salvocanocomedy.com uh love to see on
the road and i love you i love your
family i love your parents even if they
maybe you're not close to your parents
but i love them
because uh all we need is love right now
uh rolling stones
i'll tell you what here's what you do
this is i'm going to do my best you can
each name 100 i'm going to yeah i'm
going to do my best i'm going to do my
best chocolate chip cookie chocolate
cookie oatmeal cookie peanut butter
cookie butter cookie five yeah
you're eating cookies because you can't
afford ice cream and that's that's
that's the real deal you're you're it's
a good thing i think it means like man
it's ice cream is every day ice cream is
ice cream is every day ice cream shows
up and it's always there and it's
amazing every night
cakes are very big cakes are occasions
it's new money and cakes are occasions
and then uh cookies they've been around
too long they they don't even putting
any heart into it's also a great point
he's got buy screaming cake is an
occasion it's your birthday we're gonna
have cake and ice cream cookies are what
you give a toddler to keep the toddler
busy cookies are every day in and out
they're with you they're reliable no
but you're not eating them from old to
young no i know but it's stuff you're
not eating them like that to me i i
could i eat ice cream every day i and
i've got a halo top i've been eating
that because i'm trying to lose weight
it's like 300 calories
halo top is unbelievable and you're
crazy and it's like they shouldn't get
themselves ice cream they're like well
it is
flavored
no no you no no the key is you gotta
that one you do have to let sit for 15
minutes to kind of and it gets creamier
that sounds great i need it that's what
dude i don't know we're trying to invent
healthy ice cream i mean maybe give us a
break for a second all right i'm sorry
it's not just jammed down your throat
and smeared off
15 minutes we've been doing big things
over at halo top
halo top my father made it i i saw halo
top i got excited i said wow this is
gonna revolutionize ice cream and again
this is nothing against halo top it's
just the type of ice cream i bought it i
i threw it into a bowl i started to go
this doesn't taste like that's because
you ate it too quick you ate it you can
throw it in the microwave for 15 seconds
you had a cookie ice cream in the
microwave help for a second dude we're
trying to save your life with this
awesome ice cream this is like the
seinfeld episode with newman there's no
fat this is this is it this is what they
wanted to do in that seinfeld episode
they couldn't they didn't have the tools
to do something like this but now they
do it does it because you eat it too
quick and they're like my god just give
us a second dude we're trying to save
your life so you don't have to will you
out or we'll have to carry you down
steps in an emergency room because you
live in a walk-up
and you gotta the poor
paramedics got to come down tell them
hey go my god how much does this ice
cream cookie face weigh
you're trying to sell me the bill of
goods that in order for halo top to
taste like actual ice cream you got to
sit there and wait you just give it a
snap set it out
my god set it out and just go do
something for a second maybe better do
that set it up before dinner you're
going to eat dinner set it up there are
better low calorie uh ice creams halo
i've only had a little top and i don't
see how i've i started at halo top i've
i've explored correctly
there's some better ones there's a
there's a there's an almond cream one
that'll blow your socks off
and i'm i'm telling you nate i can't
tell it's not real ice cream it's i
can't tell halo if you i don't think you
guys are giving the halo the property
i had a nice dance for the company to
take to bring religion into it
i have a nice dance right now what a
halo
but i want to get back it's that good
it's something you've never seen before
it's a miracle
i want to get back to cookies for a
second every major holiday with my
family people bring different desserts
everybody brings a dessert in addition
to whatever their dish is you know what
goes the cakes
the the the the ice cream you know what
he even goes the fruit somebody always
brings fresh fruit it pisses me off but
god damn it people eat it you know
what's always left at the end a thing of
cookies that somebody bought that nobody
wants to take home yeah my mom
begging people to take the cookies home
nobody wants it in my house they end up
in a zombie bag that we throw away
cookies i'll tell you another thing
right now and i think that people line
up i'll tell you why line up i'm
throwing a party right and i on my table
in the dining room i put a tray of
cookies a beautiful tray of bakery
cookies uh a pint pints of ice cream
right there and i put a cake
the cookies are going to go faster than
those other things no that's crazy
please stand up so i can hear you
talking out of your ass clearly you're
you're intentional everybody would agree
with me you're insane you're saying
people like cookies at a holiday dessert
it's nuts
you're insane you're talking jojo you
walk into a party almost just passed out
i got so mad i almost just passed out
you're walking to a party this is nice
you walk into a party there's ice cream
a party you walk in yes there's there's
pints of briar's ice cream a half gallon
there's a a pyramid of mo oh
cookies yes and then there's one cake
are you taking a knife slicing a piece
of bacon cake okay first kidding and you
scooping out ice cream or you're going
to walk over and be like and pop a
cookie into your mouth which one are you
doing
be honest with you i'm going to say oh
cake first every single you're going to
slice your own piece of cake put it on
the plate and start eating a pizza not
only for you not only into your mouth
not only am i going to slice the cake
i'm going to slice the cake for
everybody i'm going to go across across
zig zag now everybody gets a piece
that's how i do it all right i'm going
to do it walk into someone's house and
start slicing the cake i'm gonna say
where's your cat knife give me your cake
you're not gonna stay that nobody
believes and they're gonna go
and they're they're gonna go guess what
you don't need a cake knife you can use
any knife because it's not a brick like
these cookies are and they're
you gotta have like scissors you gotta
call a guy over walk into a party hey
sir you're cutting the grass do you mind
coming in and cutting these cookies up
so people can eat them you tell me right
now wherever if you've ever been to a
party with anyone over 12 that you've
seen them walking around with a bowl of
ice cream eating nice you you imagine
walking to a party with 30 20 30 and 40
year olds and people are walking around
eating ice cream out of bowls it doesn't
happen because you cookie people are the
government and you make people feel bad
and people want they want that cake then
i would walk in i would get a slice of
cake i'd get ice cream on it and i'd
throw your cookies in the toilet and
everybody out get a stand everybody
would stand up and go thank god someone
did it someone did it because you made
these guess what you made these cookies
last night because you're too lazy to
get up a little bit early and make them
in the day so at least could have day
fresh cookies last night you made them
about seven o'clock i don't get them
until four the next day and they're
awful they're awesome so what do you do
there is no sweet there is no i froze
this so we can have it later i left it
in the freezer all night when you get it
then put it back in the freezer do you
mind doing a little there is no sweet
snack
okay like like like in this wheelhouse
that we're talking i'm not gonna count
candy because candy is is truly just to
me a snack
there's no sweet treat whatever you want
to call it dessert food
that is less underwhelming to me than
cookies when i go home after a long
night and i'm sad and i want a little
treat to help me drift off to sleep and
i say i'm going to be bad i'm going to
eat something i shouldn't eat it's ice
cream or cake it is never cookies that's
you that is never cookies that's you
babe that's you people come to someone's
house i baked your cookies they don't
say i i tell you says this
ding dong oh thank you for coming thank
you so much we changed you some ice
cream who the hell is it no they bring
ice cream they can buy to the store
because it's that good uh you can't get
you can but what are you gonna do dude
how much time do your friends have that
everybody's
i've had a homemade ice cream best ice
cream i had a long time ago i think
about it every day i wish i could have
it today
if people throw home look i'll give it
ice cream they throw homemade ice cream
on a lot of labels it's not it's not
homemade by the way
can we let's cut the [ __ ] here with the
bacon cookies routine like you're some
kind of martyr you buy a tube that looks
like a dildo in the store and you slice
them off and you put them on a pan and
throw them in the oven
a betty crocker cake takes more effort
than that babe
google from scratch do yourself a favor
go scratch
that's his version to buy the [ __ ]
pillsbury dough and slice it with a
knife and put it and by the way still
good who's doing that who's who's yeah
if they give me a choice they go uh uh
i'm gonna make some cookies or i can
make some brownies i'm gonna break
brownies they're making something not in
this battle right now but i'm just
showing you that's how much i don't want
cookies is i would be we'll just do the
brownies i would take brownie over ice
cream and cake as well well that's the
you're done look if i have that brownies
brownies cakes come on yeah brownies
brownies cake no it's not
it's like saying the milkshake is an ice
cream it's come on man what are we
talking about here a brownie see it's
it's ice cream
milkshake no you got a mcflurry you got
a
blizzard that's not ice cream that's ice
cream a blizzard's ice cream
it's but it comes from ice it's just how
you're doing it if you're eating a
little bit smoother guys we all have
chocolate flour and egg in and and well
we do so is it the same thing no it
doesn't have to be nice
very limited sorry how could you say the
most versatile of the three desserts is
limiting i'm still waiting for you to
hit me with the flavors past what i
already named you still can't do it but
you you named the five okay most popular
bakery so
first though keep going okay there's
pinolies this bakery cookies with
raspberry in the middle dipped in
chocolate there's what how much help
does the cookie need
it can't even stain on its own now now
i'm naming them
chocolate chocolate shows up by itself
and says this is what you get this i'm
here and your cookies show up with god
knows what's in them because they can't
hang on
swinging to the point that he's now into
naming cookies that only he's he's now
he's been injured
they're out of control ben jerry's is a
problem sal is now selling because your
cookie people came over it's you can't
just handle normal stuff
sal was playing with the point he's now
naming cookies that's six nana's and
steve is richard christmastime so we saw
what happened here right he turned to me
and shouted at my face to name more than
the three cookies he named i'm in the
middle of naming my fourth in a row and
now it's uh they need help nana's make
them just shut up you're not even now
you're saying like you're like uh i like
a cookie that has uh you know has some
money on top of it you ever have that no
space i got a retailer i got a cookie
that has a 20 bill on it those are good
like that's how much help a cookie needs
they got to put cash on them put icing
on cookies too and write happy birthday
deborah on them as well you could make
dick cookies nobody wants a cookie
nobody wants a cookie with ice cream oh
cookie cutter okay you can make all
sorts of fun shapes of cookies christmas
cookies snickerdoodles sugar cookies
sugar cookies are just basically you're
going i i would love to just eat sugar i
would love to drink sugar these are not
chocolate chocolate peanut butter nobody
wants the pecan cookie oreos oreos has a
thousand flavors
but what nobody wants the pizza what's
oreo's flavors all right well now you
get into blizzards
so that's blizzard but then why can't a
blizzard be ice cream all yours your
cookies can have wafers
he's got a point if your wafers can be
cookies then a milkshake is ice cream
and brownies take wafers off the table
don't try to get your [ __ ] across oh
please wait for the cookie what would
you call brownie then if it's not cake
what would you call it i would call it a
brownie no what would you call it why
isn't it called chocolate cake
because it's not chocolate cake what is
it it's a form of a chocolate chocolate
flavored cake chocolate cake
here's what
cookies cookies are you stupid [ __ ]
god if i let you argue long enough
you'll just cross your own [ __ ]
argument out cookies cookies can't stand
on their own cake and ice cream can come
on their own cookies need so much help
they have to have chocolate chips in
them they have to have like
i know but they need
all kinds of stuff
but ice cream show you get a chocolate
ice cream everybody thank you very much
for doing i love chocolate ice cream but
cookies you they just can't ever be a
vanilla wafer i'd imagine be its own
thing that's like the worst cookie of
all time but that's like that's the only
one because that's like it's like hey do
you want nate has a point like we're
trying to sell
guys
hey we're trying to move cardboard over
here so here's the vanilla wafers one of
the beauties of cookies is that you can
take this style you can take all
different ingredients everything you can
come make a cookie out of a million
things cookies but you're trying to make
it nice
ice cream can make the cookie dough good
because the cookie dough is the
beginning of a cookie and ice cream's
like look i'll help you out let me help
you out because you can't even maybe
same argument when we argue we don't
inject
cookie dough we don't inject ice cream
into our cooking well you should start
steak we inject cookie dough into the
ice cream the cookie dough is doing that
lifting it down
hold on a second though but he makes a
great point now hear me out he makes a
great point
you rarely see here all day
i'm a stroke in here
i bet you would love some ice cream
right now look at this this is the guy
cutting down halo tops yeah the guy's
[ __ ] all over his top she's gonna
have a stroke because it's 77 degrees
outside 77. i mean we're sitting in a
tinderbox here listen to me right what
levels of [ __ ] makes a great point you
re you rarely almost never see just a
cookie that's just a chocolate cookie
it's a chocolate cookie with other stuff
in it it's a vanilla cookie with other
stuff in it not true he just said you
rarely see a chocolate cookie yeah with
not without without other stuff in it it
has time for it not true i ate them last
night in my father's house
did it have chocolate chips it was just
chocolate famous chocolate wafers by
nabisco they were chocolate discs they
very much tasted like what an oreo would
taste like but they were thin crispy
chocolate discs i ate them sounds
horrendous
imagine that
your oreos
why don't you just say i bet did you
also have some black licorice
that's that's that's what you're
basically doing you're the house that
you go to and everybody says what do you
got a snack on i got black licorice i
got cookies that are no fun and you're
like oh this is a great time
disappointed i would be if i went to a
dinner party and the dessert was just
cookies i would be furious do you have
milk i would be like i got almond milk
you're setting up a scenario that is
known to have like coffee and cake so
that's your scenario that's the
wheelhouse of an after dinner usually
it's not cookies but when people ring
the bell and they come over and they say
i baked you something it's usually
cookies but you
because ice cream doesn't need help
cookies have to be no one's buying
cookies so someone has to force them
down someone's throat or they would
never eat them ice cream is just you go
buy it on your own because it's so great
that everybody wants it at their house
you can almost be positive they have it
at their house but cookies you got to
trick people into doing it you're like
oh hey i made some cookies because i've
been sitting on for four days okay and
no one wants these cookies let me ask
you guys a question okay we ring ten
bells we leave here right now go on foot
we ring ten bells and say do you have
cookies in your house do you have a cake
in your house or do you have ice cream
in your fridge they're gonna have ice
cream cake's not gonna happen
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on no no no no no i'm gonna shut
that argument down right now that's like
saying let's ring ten that's like saying
what's better milk or champagne go ring
ten bells and see who's got milk versus
champagne
cake and ice cream just because it's
like saying
milk and champagne no i'm serious how is
that like something because
these are a common food there's nothing
special about them
having potato chips in the house it's
like having pretzels in the house who
gives a [ __ ] why are they it's just
comments you're calling common you call
it common i call it popular okay all
right well
you're right the choice people are
making more than the choice of yours
right right no i think that people are
eating ice cream a lot so you you agree
though you agree that cookies will win
because you said they are water would
win in in what are you having it doesn't
mean it's better
more people more people have peanuts
more people have peanuts in their house
than cheetos it doesn't mean peanuts are
better than cheetos it's it's
commonplace of course more people are
going to have no we're talking about
three simple
foods we're talking about three of the
most staple powerhouse desserts i love
it every time he's losing he starts
saying powerhouse i just called all
three of our things titans in the
industry okay i'm sorry i didn't hear
that i thought you just met yours
they're all titans nothing is cook the
sun went behind a cloud for a second are
you still gonna have a stroke did it
cool you down cookie boy
folks have you ever been in credit card
debt more importantly high interest
credit card debt well i have most of us
have and it's terrible it can be a
horrible feeling when you have a hard
time climbing out of that hole
and upstart is a company that wants to
help you do that upstart is providing a
light at the end of that tunnel okay
saying goodbye to that high interest
credit card debt is your first step
towards financial independence all right
but when you're in that debt and the
interest is piling up month after month
after month you can feel like you're on
a hamster wheel that's where upstart
comes in okay upstart powered personal
loans can help you pay down your high
interest loan debt all online with
simple easy to use and understand
payment terms upstart has helped over
1.8 million customers on their path to
financial freedom whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses upstart can help you get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date
upstart knows that you're more than just
your credit score which a lot of
companies will make you feel like like
like all of a sudden well let's see what
your score is as if that's you have no
more
and that sucks because sometimes you get
into a little trouble and you're
actually responsible and have money
coming in but your score is still
screwed
let upstar help okay because you're
worth more than that score all right
they're uh they they realize that and
their model considers other factors like
your income and employment and your
information provided when they're
considering your loan applications
you're not going to be defined just by
that credit score when you're applying
for one of these loans you can check
your rate your credit or sorry you can
check your rate in minutes uh for loans
between 100 1000 to 50 000
uh and none of this impacts your credit
score because that's the other thing
sometimes when you're trying to just
figure out what you're eligible for your
score gets affected or negatively hit
upstart isn't going to do that again
perusing the possibilities for you from
loans ranging from one thousand up to
fifty thousand dollars it's not going to
affect your score when you look into
this go do this for yourself if you need
some help
don't wait check your credit rate today
at upstart.com tastebuds again
upstart.com taste buds that's
upstart.com tastebuds to check your rate
today and don't forget to use
our url to let them know that we sent
you that url is upstart.com tastebuds
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided on your loan
application go to upstart.com tastebuds
what's up chicky ds uh i want to talk to
you about bespoke post okay bespoke post
take your summer adventures to the next
level of bespoke post in their new
seasonal lineup of must-have box of
awesome collections
bespoke post partners with small
businesses and emerging brands to bring
you the most unique goods every month um
i've i've had three bespoke post boxes
so far uh i i got a machete delivered to
my house uh and it's i'm gonna chop down
uh the weeds in my backyard with it i
had i would never buy a machete
otherwise but uh they have all these
different categories that you might like
so
i also got uh the terra box and it came
with a knife
that was made by bare bones it's based
in salt lake city so that's the cool
thing about it you are uh
supporting small businesses when you do
it no matter what you have going on this
season box is awesome as you're covered
from camping gear essentials beach day
travels and must-haves box of awesome
has everything you need for the summer
uh there's a new one in here because i'm
doing a lot of traveling this summer
called the weekender it's another thing
i've never done was being able to buy
uh a bag for suits what do they call
that
garment bag garment bag i'm always uh
i'm always like thinking about getting
one i never had that's what's so cool
about so they have this weekender i got
a dark blue one it features metal
hardware reinforced frames and quality
leather straps what's up buddy
little kid just roamed into the
room from the street everybody looks
like he is adorable he is buddy hey what
do you think about bespoke post where's
your
where's your family too
all right god bless that kid
uh so he's that kid that kid
looked like a 53 year old man he did
he looked like he looked like a big pun
as a child
to get started take the quiz at boxing
awesome.com so they know what you like
and you don't like and they'll and
they'll
give you suggestions based on that your
answers help them pick the right box for
you they release new boxes every month
tons of different categories like we
said each box is valued at about new
york city baby street sweeper new york
each box is valued at around 70 bucks
you pay at a fraction that price and
again you're supporting small business
90 of everything that comes from there
is from a small and upcoming brand get
20 off your first box uh your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome dot com and enter the code taste
buds at checkout that's box of awesome
dot com code taste buds for 20 off your
first box box of awesome.com
code tastebuds
they're all popular and i think we've
pissed off everybody on the street by
the way you agree with me look at this
the people at the coffee shop are going
inside they're pissing everybody people
are looking in here like what is going
on yeah you just agreed with me what the
heck would win that and you you tried to
cover it up by saying cookies whole
common foods but when because they're
common not win because they're better
that doesn't mean they're better that
more people have them joe you're telling
me ice cream is not common fake is not
cool
listen to you know what people don't
have
you know what people don't choose
you know why people don't have kids
you know why people don't have kid in
the house i can't have it now.com eat
that's why
ice cream is common cake is common
cookies are common cookies aren't in
more houses i don't keep ice cream and
cake in my house because i can't be
trusted with it you keep cookies in your
house i got bags oh my god i got bags
let's break down exactly what he just
said right now he's arguing against
cookies tooth and nail and i just asked
him what do you have in your house cake
cookies or ice cream he says i do not
have kids ice cream i don't have cake i
only have cookies in it did i say i
bought this man did i say about it out
loud he doesn't have cake or ice cream
what party you know only cookies did i
say you have something to say to me did
i say i bought them number one did i say
bought the cookies what's in your house
i don't care if you
they were in a gift basket that my
parents gave why why wasn't the cake in
the basket because they brought a cake
for the holiday we ate some of it and
then they took the rest home
i don't think my parents ever bought me
a gift basket
they gave my parents gave me a gift
basket for easter it had some cookies in
it i put them in the closet i never i
feel like that's a weird gift for people
why do i not have a child
gift basket why do i not have cake and
ice cream in my house because i will eat
it right so
when do you eat it then
on special occasions because i don't
like because i'm trying to look out for
my diet so the cookie is
is everywhere i have way more ice cream
than a cookie cookie sits there right
dust in my house not even not even
cooking that is you and you choose ice
cream is your favorite but if you if you
take a poll yeah cookie but if someone
goes you got cookies that go i don't
yeah i mean i bought something
i have it in my house [ __ ] i definitely
got a ticket
if they got a halo well you deserve it
if they have a halo if they made a halo
top cake can you continue while i paid
my meter you got a ticket already let it
go just let it get on yeah yeah if i
don't i don't want to get a 150 ticket
yeah yeah let's just finish it yeah all
right if you live in this society
we're at like 40 40. again yeah we
didn't wait at a split point we'll just
cut it and do it yeah yeah when they
make a halo top cake i'll put him i'll
put a kayla top cake in my house i once
in a while of ice cream and usually and
it's big and when i do it's some sort of
version of a halo top thing and i don't
even keep that in the house because i'm
trying not to eat the sugar cookies i
don't give a [ __ ] about they're in my
house because i got them as a gift and i
don't care and proof positive that much
i don't care is they sit there
collecting dust and i don't eat them
they have to be fresh made i just don't
want to throw them away cookies have to
be out of the oven like no cookies good
no cookie has renewing qualities at all
and you don't like cookies that's not
true i didn't know i'm just saying i'm
not tempted i don't like cake i'm just
saying cookies are the best of those
three if you eat them out of the oven
cookies are unbelievable but that's it
after that it's it's a piece of rock
that's floating through the sky rock is
the frozen ice cream that you have to
eat 15. it's not frozen dude no that's
no that's it it depends what kind of
freezer you got all right and so you get
a freezer most ice cream briars you put
in our freezer you cut out you just
scoop it in you're gonna eat it dude we
have a great ice cream scoop maybe go
buy a good ice cream scoop you're doing
it with a teaspoon so i mean you're like
yeah i'd have i'd hate ice cream if i
didn't have the tools special you need
special utensils and tools to have your
ice cream you need a spatula to get the
cookies there because it's going to
stick to the thing that you got it on
you can't even touch it that's the other
thing you got to use a shovel and you
got to bring someone in again you got to
hire outside and you got to bring
someone in some construction crew and
get them to like just get it off the pan
that's the other thing too that nate
brings up a great point ice cream never
made wrong ice cream is always ice cream
basically cake even when it's made
poorly you can still salvage the middle
part oh [ __ ] yeah the cake at home
cooking something the cake drops when my
mom used to bake cookies it was like can
i shut the [ __ ] up for 90. let me finish
my point cookies
oh god you get a bad one that's it
that's it how about you it's not
like you said you're gonna go you go buy
any cake anywhere it's probably gonna be
great ice cream don't even question it
it's gonna be good and they're even
doing gelato
i think when you go get a cookie
good luck good luck you know why you
think you guys are coming at me because
cookie is the thing that has to be the
has to be argued against the most
because it is the clear winner you know
today i did i noticed something today
something registered with me today this
was a classic derose app where you had
terrible arguments no i didn't yeah this
is you're going to see in the comments
we're like oh god derose's argument how
were my arguments terrible read the
comments i you i couldn't barely get a
word in because you're screaming about
cookies because i i i wanted to bring
the heat today you brought the heat
i will tell you this right now this is
all i need to say about cake it's moist
it's got delicious icing it comes in a
versatile array of flavors it is a treat
when you get it it is a joy at the end
of the meal when somebody bakes it
cookies when somebody when somebody
bakes one for you it means so much more
than a cookie it's up there with pie in
the effort department it's it's
just what else is there to say
everything you said in every single
thing
you could have said you if i didn't know
what you were talking about it could
also apply to antamens entamones amazing
cakes front to back they're cookies i
could care less about their cookies uh
stelladoro take a hike i don't care you
already know my thoughts on oreos
swiss fudge is one of the best cookies
ever made
i like the idea that you when you get
done eating uh you smoke cigarette you
can put it out in your ice cream you
ever see did people do that that looks
good
how's it going
what are you going to do it's going to
re-light it you put it on there
people use the matches and they're just
going on a cookie cake and ice cream you
can have cake and ice cream together or
you can have them both solo and you're
happy cookies every person i know
besides me when they have a cookie has
to have milk with it and i stand by my
argument that if you can't have it by
itself then your food has got a problem
i stand by it i like that nobody nobody
could eat a cookie by itself you're
right yeah you told me nine you have
said these exact words to me you can
remember in under five times in your
life when you haven't dunked a cookie
that's my that's my preference i could
eat a cookie without milk no problem of
course you can
you need a hot dog with no mustard who
the hell wants to milk you know you're
living a lie is what
is that you you're going to eat these
cookies alone because you're being
programmed to think this is what you're
supposed to do but cookies need to can't
wait for my
birthday could you imagine on your
birthday if your mom goes we're going to
get you cookies they get a cookie cake
the occasion that a cake that's the
cake's wheelhouse hey just saying funny
i was thinking for our wedding what if
we just got a coke in case yeah you got
divorced
you got special occasions on lock with
the cake and i have the other 360 days
of the year after the funeral everybody
come back to our place for cookies and
coffee
i think you're cooking i would carry
your the
way i would defend cookies ice cream is
murdering the united states of america
it's murder oh yeah cookies are doing
great so it's uh i would say with your
cake out of all the things it's what i
would want in a street fight
to have why because it's so hard that i
think i could damage someone's head with
it
that's yeah i would want it as a weapon
i was a weapon i would put a half gallon
of ice cream in a plastic shopping bag
and spin it like a sock with a sack of
nickels i could clunk you could drop ice
cream you might tell me you you somebody
you and your guys go become friends
because he goes what's that ice cream
you hit me with it it's going to be
amazing
go up this fire escape right here drop
an oreo see what happens yeah go up
there drop a half gallon of broiler's
ice cream and kill somebody someone's
gonna catch it take it home you know
what i want a street fight a cake
here's why guy goes i'm gonna kill you i
go how about some cake he'll go and
forget about it forget about it forget
about it you're gonna have a nice
afternoon with that man yeah yeah
exactly all right pimp
this is it i do want to run one thing by
you you see the new ritz cracker
collaborated with oreo to make a half
ritz no why absolutely disgusting that
sounds insane yeah absolutely
these people
these people got two
all right
it's fine i'll vamp while you're gone
joe this is what people want on the
podcast is just you
i know
you're gonna see the numbers spike i
know
i know
i mean there's there's gonna be more
people that are just like ah you
remember when sal paid
sal drove here today from the set of his
seventh tv show yeah he's running to pay
a 65 ticket right now yeah
jesus christ this guy unreal i don't
want to get a ticket
[Laughter]
he's on the network they just air it all
day long god dude he spends that money
in tic tacs yeah
it's like what is he doing what do you
guys think of all the new fish flavored
ice cream there's like salmon and
oysters no that's crazy that's crazy i
had that ice cream they
where's that at
uh i forget
i think van lewins makes it it was
really gross i've never
been i don't know it was one of those
uh a mint chip mint chocolate chip fan i
was not a fan and i've really
yeah i get in a a group i'm i'm a very
normal chocolate
uh you know chocolate's my number one i
never i love hershey's syrup on vanilla
though you mix it up and then you pound
it and then you stir it up and it's it's
because then it turns it into chocolate
that's why well i just like to do some
exercise before i get there but what you
just said is you're turning your vanilla
you go as long as i can turn it into
chocolate with syrup because vanilla's
because i mean look i don't think she
looks i know but i but if you have good
vanilla it can be really good but that's
going to be like the odds of finding a
good cause she said this about vanilla
when we argued it when i get when i have
like when it's like a neapolitan ice
cream i go to the vanilla just to
prevent me from eating all the
strawberry and chocolate ice cream
because it's so good i go to the vanilla
as like as like a governor to be like
just take a bite of that so you don't
need all the best part yet you know what
i mean like that's literally what i use
vanilla i leave strawberry i'll leave it
in it and throw it away huh that's how
much you won't eat strawberry if i got
that nib
no
i don't know i don't think i like a lot
of strawberry stuff
i will give you this strawberry flavor
versus actual strawberry taste
is is is there's it's different it's not
as severe as watermelon flavor versus
watermelon which i love watermelon
flavor i hate watermelon fruit i love
banana fruit i hate banana flavor
because the flavors versus the fruit
taste is so different but strawberry is
one that teeters on it where there is
like
there is like a like like strawberry
flavor
there's like an effervescence to it or
something where it almost opens up your
sinuses
where you're like whoa wow that's a
strawberry right there baby you know
what do you guys think of italian ices
yeah i like them too i like that kind of
stuff but i have to have it very
specifically i have to have
predominantly lemon
with a little bit of strawberry cherry
if it's too much cherry it ruins it for
me but lemon's always got to be the
basically with italian ice the tartness
of that
is what i'm there for people that eat
chocolate italian ice i think are
psychopaths i think it's a truly like
that's a sick thing yeah that's that's
weird
what uh so weird it's nice that's like a
slushy right like it's yeah no it's like
hard ice that you scrape off with a
little wooden spoon oh what's the
difference here
a slushie is slush like it's like
literally like slushy
now because it's chunky ice
it's not like a slurpee but you drink a
slushie but it's like an icy's like that
too it's actually like chunked ice
with like a syrup mixed in that gives it
flavor italian ice is hard like you have
to make you have to let italian ice melt
a little bit before you can eat it but
even then it it
it scoops off almost like the way ice
cream does yeah
and then it's hey where's his car it was
not right there
he said his car was like right there
and it's not right there he probably got
a ticket he's probably having a panic
attack because you gotta take it
i see him walking down yeah but a lot of
the fans are writing that uh cake and
cookies are useless without ice cream
that well they're both accessories i'll
accept that argument i get that but not
with cookies yeah but cookies need i
think cookies need ice cream helpful
well i just think it's weird to say
cookies and ice cream just go together
all the time i don't think they don't go
together but they're always going to be
good and like ice cream like
if someone goes eric cookies and ice
cream you're going to be like yeah
absolutely i win yet
no that's fine i trashed you the whole
time you were going about how panicked
you were about a 65 ticket
did you get a ticket huh no i didn't
think i know but i still it's restful i
know but it's fun to trash you about you
have to know just being transparent
trash me about worrying about getting a
ticket you run your life by your parking
garage his parking garage he he joins a
parking garage that closes at midnight
do you understand times a month he looks
at his watch he goes
i gotta go my parking garage closes at
midnight i go you're letting this root
rule your life you understand he runs
home like cinderella one second do you
understand how famous you are
that's why i make fun not because of the
talking about the famous
of you
can afford the you could afford a
24-hour parking garage i don't live near
one i keep telling you that walk the
extra three blocks instead of going it's
not 10 45. not an extra three blocks
it's an extra 15 minute walk ever since
you joined that garage i've watched you
slowly ruined your life oh my god let me
tell you the amount of smells and i'm
not joking the amount of smells i
smelled to that corner and to the next
corner it's not a great show
and there were like 20 smells and like
15 of them were like
gut-wretching it's not a great thing
it's not a great streak there's a smell
about four story smell departments most
likely actually come [ __ ] come down to
joey it's a great streak it is
aggressive joey roses everybody 174
ravington street we're here now in the
rv just to plug it one more time we're
open tuesday through sunday
joeyrosesnyc.com come visit us this was
our first ever two-part episode of taste
buds boy did it get heated as we used to
say on the you know what dude podcast
this was a goddamn gator fight today
all right
let's uh see
the phones you got anything you want to
plug bud
uh my tour i go on my website uh
daveburgetsy.com i got a bunch of summer
dates and then the fall dates are up uh
go check them out all right i love you
guys do not know nate one of the best
comics in the country come on please go
see me thank you yes
all right yeah so here we go this is
called the humble pie okay because
somebody's gonna eat something all right
we get a drumroll right now pimp goes to
the polls we can't see the screen like
usual so pimp you're gonna have to tell
us
[Music]
what 16 is cake
yeah
[Laughter]
i love it you love to see it you love to
see it you love to see him go on a
two-hour self-righteous diatribe and
then eat his own nuts you'll love it
uh second place with 32
wait wait wait 16 means is 84 left okay
which means that 82 that means if
something at 32 the winner uh has 50 56
you can do math no but let's slow it
down even more i just want to see how
big the disparity is between the second
and the first place okay all right so 32
is cookies ah
i mean it feels coming to
did you know cake was coming in last
place should dildo no but i knew but i
knew ice cream was going to be cookies
yeah ice cream or did you think you
stood in it ice cream already beat
cookies i thought cake had a chance of
taking the crap i thought cake was going
to be a wild horse and let me tell you
ice cream no no that's what i'm saying
dominating once i saw cake was in third
i was like okay ice cream won i'll be
honest it doesn't it's thank you for
everybody uh for being just a normal
person and a good you know that you
understand life and they
but it's like it is not a fair fight ice
cream is doing that good i gotta be
honest i can't believe ice cream wins
ice cream is are the things i don't
understand cookies ice cream cake cookie
rank them
to you
to me yeah
cake ice cream cookie
exactly
exactly how to cake at 16
i'm gonna go ice cream and cookies cake
okay i'd go ice cream cake cookies i go
cookies cake ice cream and i'm doing
cookies just because you're here i can't
believe cake got hit that hard i can't
16 percent that's nuts i don't think
cake's in people's lives though you're
you're like eddie murphy
you
like
cookies cookies and ice cream are very
much in people's lives and cake's not uh
it's not reached to the point where it's
like just kind of like oh you want a
nice piece of cake you have ice cream
half a year only no you have ice cream
all the time it's that good
and i'll go to uh get a sonic blast uh
uh
let's take a blizzard it's not as good
as a blizzard a blizzard is another
level but he just brought up mcdonald's
he he filled your mcdonald's mcflurry
bring it up beautiful he didn't bring it
up he brings up mcdonald's and that
already
i think we should show mcdonald's more
uh respect i think you should wear
tuxedo mcdonald's they go it's an honor
to even open the door for me we're the
most successful restaurant in history
mcdonald's versus wendy's it's not even
close
i know oh mcdonald's
yeah uh you're the winner so you have to
say you still love us that's how it ends
oh i love i love you i still love you i
still love you we still love you too
yeah all right taste buds they coming to
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds